let's talk about Zombieland I got to see
this sequel I compliment you very much
because the first movie was so great and
then there's a lot of pressure on the
sequel the sequel is hilarious yeah fast
paced and a great story yeah it's really
fun and then we you and I have both had
this experience which is I got to do
this once you got to drive a monster
truck in this movie I have to say I did
it was a religious experience to drive a
monster truck you know I still I drove
it like it was a Prius but I was so very
cautious and I put my blinker on
as I rolled over other cars but who
created them he built them he drives
them like all of the stunts in it he
actually did by hand who's the special
effects Keith who made it oh the guy and
he takes his kids to school in the
monster truck right like here's your
lunch I mean I just feel like you're
never in traffic school buses what was
that the third grade
the whole thing I I mean it's good I
mean Cory leaned over in the middle of
the premiere and just went really good
movie yeah I'm like normally you save
that for the ads like you really liked
it so instead it was sort of just kind
of this moment like it's a little
insulting like if my wife is with me and
we're watching something I did and she
leans over and goes this is good I'm
very insulted thank who knew okay
fortunately that's never happened we
have a clip here I believe this is your
this is pretty early on I think this is
what introducing your character is that
right she's she's in this awesome we we
turned this made this hotel that looks
just like Graceland mm-hmm which was
really really fun to shoot it I have to
say we did this and after this moment
that you see there's this an amazing
shootout that ends up happening they
should a great scene three days right
and it's just all seamless like the way
it's all cut together it was so
brilliant as a fan of the first movie to
sit there and watch this one get made
was just so amazing I got to do fun
stuff like you're about to see right now
but I had to keep being reminded to act
it was like alright I'm not just behind
the scenes alright
the I have to say the character you play
in this movie is the person that I would
want to spend the apocalypse with you
you are because you're beautiful also
you are incredibly badass and I think
you wait on you would look after me in
the apocalypse you probably more
important let's take this clip from
Zombieland double tab whoa the Beast
yeah Wow replace it ain't grace sure
looks a hell of a lot like Graceland
here's ya get it or split up no no no I
should talk to her I'm her sister I'll
talk to her first
you stay here
[Music]
I'm never abandon start talking are you
first huh my name's Tallahassee Nevada
which part
Nevada is as close as you get
[Applause]